[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian siebas ihnen allen
guten Abend wir beginnen mit
Selbstkritik die internationalen Medien
sind nicht besonders gut im Multitasking
wenn es um die Berichterstattung von
internationalen Brennpunkten geht wenn
sich Nachrichten überschlagen tendieren
wir dazu einen Konflikt besonders in den
Fokus zu nehmen sodass man fast denken
könnte alle anderen Konflikte seien
gelöst das gilt auch aktuell im Nahen
Osten heute wieder aufatmen und Bangen
weitere Familien in Israel können Ihre
Liebsten in die Arme schließen zurück
aus der Hand der
Hammers in Gaza sind aber tausende auf
der Suche nach dem was noch übrig ist
von ihrem im bisherigen Leben und sie
finden flächendeckende Zerstörung wir
berichten über beide Seiten
selbstverständlich in dieser Sendung
aber es gilt eben auch im Osten nichts
Neues der Krieg gegen die Ukraine geht
jeden Tag weiter und er eskaliert gerade
wieder mit den schlimmsten
Drohnenangriffen auf Kiev seitdem der
russische Überfall begann und so wie in
Israel heute neun verschleppte Kinder
freikamen und damit noch mal deutlich
machen wie menschenverachtend jemand ist
der Kinder als Geiseln nimmt so wird
auch das Schicksal der Ukraine besonders
klar am Leid ihrer Kinder Tim Kröger ist
im Süden des Landes unterwegs
überall in diesem Ort dessen Namen und
Standort wir aus Sicherheitsgründen
nicht nennen dürfen sind die Spuren der
Kämpfe zu sehen noch immer gibt es
regelmäßig Angriffe und doch leben
Kinder hier seit vier Wochen haben sie
diese kleine Bibliothek ein
Hoffnungsschimmer im Kriegs
Alltag hier können wir
zusammenkommen ich lese und ich bastele
hier ohne die Bibliothek gäbe es für die
Kinder wie die 13-Jährige Ivanka kaum
etwas zu tun beide Schulen im Ort sind
zerstört das Internet läuft schlecht
onlineunterricht ist
schwierig natürlich langweilen sich die
Kinder aber hier organisiere ich solche
Treffen und wir sprechen über
verschiedene Themen
vor allem in Ortschaften so nah an der
Front sind die Auswirkungen des Krieges
auf die Kinder nur schwer zu erahnen die
Bibliothek wird durch private Spenden
aus allen Teilen der Ukraine finanziert
Menschen schicken Bücher bald schon soll
es mehr solcher minibibliotheken in
anderen Dörfern geben denn hier haben
die Kinder einen Ort für soziale
Kontakte das ist sehr wichtig hier
können sie miteinander reden ohne das
könnten sie keine Kinder sein es ist
schwierig online zu lernen hier könen
Sie
kommunizen das hilft den Kindern
vielleicht etwas mit den traumatischen
Situationen dieses Krieges umzugehen
erst kürzlich gab es
Beschuss Bruchteile flogen herum Gott
sei Dank bei uns war alles in Ordnung
aber ich hatte große Angst Ivanka gab
den Impuls zur Bibliothek sie wollte
lesen und das Leben war zu trist in
ihrem Heimatort den sie wegen der
Zerstörungen kaum
wiedererkennt sehr verändert wegen der
Ruinen überall jetzt sieht es schon ein
bisschen besser aus denn viele Leute
haben ihre Häuser wieder
aufgebaut trotz allem hat iwanka
Zukunftspläne sie will Psychologin oder
Designerin werden diesen Traum lässt sie
sich nicht nehmen obwohl der Krieg schon
bald zwei Jahre
andauert was ist aus diesem Krieg
geworden und was steht den Menschen in
der Ukraine noch bevor gerade jetzt im
beginnenden Winter Dara Hassan Sade mit
einem aktuellen Überblick
Schneesturm bei Odessa der Winter hat
heute auch den Süden der Ukraine
erreicht die Menschen fürchten nicht so
sehr das Verkehrschaos sondern russische
Luftangriffe auf ihre Städte auf
Kraftwerke und Umspannwerke sie fürchten
einen Winter ohne Strom und Heizung so
wie der
vergangene das ganze Wochenende
russische drohenangriffe auch auf die
Hauptstadt Kiev noch reichen die
Munitionsbestände der Ukraine Flugabwehr
noch hat Russland aber nur wenige
Marschflugkörper gegen Infrastruktur
eingesetzt alleine auf der Krim Lagern
mehr als 800 russische Raketen an der
Front hat die ukrainische Großoffensive
keine durchbrechenden Erfolge gebracht
allerdings konnten ukrainische Einheiten
den Fluss tnibro überqueren und
Stellungen am Ostufer halten strategisch
bedeutend um russische Nachschublinien
im Süden künftig zu
unterbrechen
schwer umkämpft ist die Stadt avdivka im
Osten im Donbass ist die Ukraine in der
Defensive ukrainische Soldaten halten
die Stellungen seit Wochen gegen eine
russische Übermacht bei den Angriffen
auf die Stadt habe die russische Armee
nach ukrainischen Angaben bereits über
10.000 Soldaten verloren doch Russland
greift weiter an und auf ukrainischer
Seite wird die Munition knapp eine
Million Artilleriegeschosse hat die EU
versprochen aber bisher etwa nur ein
Drittel
geliefert und was heißt all das für die
Welt fragen wir Christian Mölling
Politikwissenschaftler Fachgebiet
Sicherheit und Verteidigung bei der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik guten Abend Herr Mölling hallo
guten Abend Herr Sivers ist die Ukraine
dabei diesen Krieg zu verlieren
wir haben ja von vorne rein gesagt dass
alles das was in der Ukraine passiert
Gewinnen oder Verlieren ganz stark davon
abhängt was der Westen liefert oder auch
nicht liefert also es ist auch unsere
ähm sozusagen unsere Verantwortung die
die wir dort sehen wie weit wir sie
wahrnehmen oder nicht wahrnehmen aber
man kann zur Zeit sagen ja es sieht
zurzeit nicht
gut aus Russland spielt auf Zeit und die
Ukraine bekommt nicht das was ihr
zugesagt worden ist
ähm von daher ist es zur Zeit so dass
man sich schon fragen muss
wie sehen wir auf das nächste halbe Jahr
denn ganz klar ist nach diesem Winter
möchte die Ukraine gerne die nicht so
Offensive starten rüstet der Westen die
Ukraine in diese Richtung aus es ist ja
vielleicht nicht nur der nächste Winter
der Oberbefehlshaber der ukrainischen
Armee spricht von einer patsituation und
einem Zitat zermürbenden Grabenkrieg der
sich über Jahre hinziehen könnte hat der
Westen dafür die
Geduld möglicherweise hat er das nicht
der ukrainische oberkommandier hat aber
auch gesagt was man tun kann um da
rauszukommen ich glaube wenn man sagt
wir haben die Geduld dafür nicht
gleichzeitig ist aber unsere Sicherheit
mit der der Ukraine verbunden dann sind
wir offensicht aber zur Zeit nicht
bereit in der Lage die Konsequenzen
daraus zuuziehen also wir gucken nicht
nur auf die Ukraine wir gucken auch wie
das Kaninchen vor der Schlange auf das
was in Washington passiert wir sehen
eigentlich all die wesentlichen
Ereignisse die dazu führen dass nicht
nur die Situation der Ukraine sondern
auch unsere eigene schlechter wird aber
die Konsequenz im Handeln die fehlt zur
Zeit sie haben gerade Washington
angesprochen also die Frage wie viele
Hilfe aus Washington aus den USA
weiterhin Richtung Ukraine kommt und
dann auch die Frage ob möglicherweise
Donald Trump zurückkehrt ins Weiße Haus
warum kümmert oder warum scheint das
Europa im Moment so wenig zu kümmern als
dass wir uns schon konkret darauf
vorbereiten würden ja ich glaube es es
kümmert uns als als ein Ereignis von dem
alle wissen dass es kommt weil es so
sicher ist aber wir nutzen die Phase
davor nicht man könnte beiden jetzt ja
quasi unterstützen auch dadurch dass man
eben die Ukraine nicht zu einem solchen
Wahlkampfthema machen nicht dass es dazu
kommt dass es so ein Wahlkampfthema wird
indem die Europäer mehr mehr
Verantwortung und damit einfach mehr
Last übernehmen für diesen Konflikt und
die Ukraine unterstützen aber da
zögern wir tatsächlich zumindest ein
Teil der Europäer ein wichtiger Teil der
Europäer ist sich zurzeit nicht im
Klaren was es eigentlich machen will um
die Ukraine weiter zu unterstützen wenn
die Amerikaner Wegbrechen der
Bundeskanzler hat schon vor längerer
Zeit gesagt mit der Waffe an der Schläfe
lässt sich nicht verhandeln das sieht
man aber offenbar ja nicht mehr überall
so wird am Ende Kiev an den verhandlungs
gedrängt selbst wenn Kiev an den
Verhandlungstisch gedrängt wird ist das
eben nicht das Ende diese Idee glaube
ich macht sich zur Zeit so hier und da
in einer Ecke in in Berlin breit dass
man eigentlich hofft man mussste noch
ein paar Monate aushalten dann wäre es
vorbei und dann wäre es so wie früher
aber ich glaube das ist der Trugschluss
es wird nicht mehr so wie früher werden
die Ukraine wird auch nicht bereit sein
eine Millionen ihrer Menschen und 10
tausende von Kindern in russischer
Gewalt
zurückzulassen und die Frage ist ob das
was Europa versprochen hat entweder dass
Russland nicht gewinnen darf oder aber d
so dass sogar die Ukraine gewinnt ob all
diese Versprechungen und auch die
Sicherheitsgarantien die angesprochen
worden sind ob die irgendwas wert sind
wir entscheiden hier glaube ich gerade
in erheblichen Maße darüber wie
vertrauenswürdig wir eigentlich als
Europa noch sind aber wenn es wie sie
sagen nicht mehr so wird wie früher und
wenn es auch so wie es aktuell läuft ja
letztlich nicht lange weitergehen kann
was bleibt denn dann noch
na wir haben noch handlungskapazitäten
also ähm wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
alles das was heute passiert oder auch
nicht passiert den Krieg in sech Monaten
beeinflusst dann gibt es quasi eine neue
Liste von all den Dingen die die Ukraine
braucht um im nächsten Jahr eben nicht
in einen Stellungskrieg zu rutschen oder
dort wenn sie dort jetzt schon ist den
weiterzuführen sondern tatsächlich die
Fähigkeit zu haben daraus auszubrechen
und weitere Erfolge zu machen die Frage
ist ob die Europäer sagen ja okay wir
sind bereit da rein zu investieren wir
gehen auch ins Risiko bislange sieht es
nicht so aus als ob wir bereit sind das
Risiko
einzugehen ich würde gerne noch zum
Schluss ganz kurz auf das ganz große
Bild gucken ich habe heute einen Satz
eines Historikers gelesen der mir nicht
mehr aus dem Kopf geht Kriege wie diese
sagt der und der meint D mit den Ukraine
Krieg haben Konsequenzen die Jahrzehnte
andauern wer diesen Krieg verliert oder
gewinnt das wird uns alle auf 10 20 und
vielleicht noch viel mehr Jahre prägen
ist das allen bewusst
m ich habe den Eindruck dass es nicht
allen bewusst ist vor allen Dingen nicht
denjen die die Entscheidungen treffen
wichtiger ist aber ähm dass man das
nicht in Jahrzehnten messen muss sondern
dass man relativ klar sagen muss dass
uns die äh die Konsequenzen wenn wir der
Ukraine nicht helfen und damit unsere
eigene Sicherheit weiterhin gefährden
dass uns diese Konsequenzen
wahrscheinlich schon in fünf oder sechs
Jahren ins Haus stehen werden weil
Russland sich auf der einen Seite
ermutigt fühlt dass man Erfolg haben
kann mit Krieg um seine Interessen
durchzusetzen und gleichzeitig quasi die
die Ernte einfahren wird aus seiner
angelaufenen Kriegswirtschaft und damit
im Grund der Lage sein wird Europa
weiterhin zu bedrohen und dann geht es
nicht um die Frage ob es einen
Nuklearschlag oder nukleare Eskalation
gegen Kiev geht sondern um eine nukleare
Eskalation die möglicherweise dann
Berlin ins Zentrum rückt Christian
Mölling vielen Dank für ihre Expertise
heute abend ich danke ihnen schönen
Abend Ihnen auch auch wenn es keine
guten Aussichten sind was dem russischen
Präsidenten und seinem Krieg gegen die
Ukraine gerade zweifellos in die Hände
spielt dass die Welt abgelenkt ist weil
sie sich mit einem weiteren Krieg besch
die mediale und die politische
Aufmerksamkeit liegen aktuell in Nahost
wo es heute neue Hoffnung gibt in Israel
dass weitere Geiseln aus hamasand
freikommen und neues bangen ob die
eigenen geliebten Menschen dabei sind
und währenddessen sind in Gaza immer
mehr Menschen unterwegs um
herauszufinden was von ihrem Zuhause
noch übrig ist in vielen Fällen nichts L
walport hat die aktuelle
Lage hing die geiselvereinbarung lange
in der Schwebe heute übergab die
Terrorgruppe Hamas 17 Geiseln weitgehend
ohne Verzögerung 14 Israelis D
Thailänder unter den freigelassenen eine
84jährige gesundheitlich schwer
angeschlagene Frau der Terror der Hamas
auch ein zentrales Thema des Gesprächs
von Bundespräsident steinmeierer mit
israelspräsident Herzog am Abend in
Jerusalem nichts ist
vergessen nicht derjenigen die ihre
Angehörigen verloren
haben und wir vergessen nicht die
Berichte und Bilder aus den ersten
Tagen nach dem 7 Oktober nach dem
brutalen
terrorüberfall der Hamas zuvor hatte der
Bundespräsident zusammen mit
Bundestagspräsidentin Bass Angehörige
deutsch-israelischer Geiseln besucht sie
fordern Unterstützung zur Freilassung
der
entführten sollte die Hauptaufgabe sein
bis alle freigekommen
sind einen solchen Augenblick schirer
Freude konnte Familie Hand gestern
erleben die neunjährige Emily nach 50
Tagen Geiselhaft wieder bei ihrem Vater
die Familie dachte zunächst sie sei
unter den Todesopfern der Terrorangriffe
der Hamas dann warteten sie wochenlang
auf die ersehnte Freilassung von Emily
gestern die
Erlösung Freude und Jubel auch heute
Abend im Westjordanland in m wurden
weitere 39 palästinensische Häftlinge
von ihren Familien empfangen zuvor waren
sie aus israelischen Haftanstalten
entlassen worden kein Anlass zur Freude
hingegen in gasastadt wo Tausende von
Bewohnern die in Schutzräumen ausgehartt
hatten die Feuerpause nutzten um nach
ihrem Haus zu schauen und Lebensmittel
zu beschaffen annähend jedes zweite
Gebäude hier ist beschädigt oder
zerstört wir werden den Kampf fortsetzen
das betonte Israels Regierungschef
netanah bei einem Truppenbesuch GA eine
Verlängerung der Feuerpause und weitere
geiselfreilassungen schloss er aber
nicht
aus es gibt einen Fahrplan der besagt
dass man jeden weiteren Tag Feuerpause
zehn weitere Geiseln befreien könnte das
wäre ein sien und auch aus Washington
kommen ähnliche
Signale das ist mein Ziel die Feuerpause
über morgen hinaus zu verlängern damit
mehr Geiseln freikommen und mehr Hilfe
nach Gaza
gelangt den Gase für die leidgeprüften
Familien wäre das eine gute
Nachricht noch ist Krieg aber eine große
Frage für die Zeit danach stellt sich
bereits jetzt wie soll in Gaza
angesichts der Zerstörung wieder Leben
möglich sein oder anders gefragt wer
soll all das wieder aufbauen das wird
wenn überhaupt wohl nicht ohne die
Vereinten Nationen gehen auch wenn das
Verhältnis zwischen israels Regierung
und der UNO seit vielen Jahren aus
gesprochen angespannt ist um es
vorsichtig zu sagen aktuell kann man es
fast feindselig nennen das UNO Hilfswerk
für Palästina Flüchtlinge im Nahen Osten
im unoprech kurz unwra genannt gibt es
bereits seit
1949 die Organisation ist für Gaza
ebenso lebenswichtig wie sie in Israel
misstrauisch beugt wird dominik
lesmeister hat mehr
dazu Hilfe für die Palästinenser das
leistet kümmern Sie sich vor allem um
die Versorgung der Menschen im
Gasastreifen sorgen für Lebensmittel und
Hilfstransporte ein eigenes
flüchtlingswerk nur für die
Palästinenser wir haben den Auftrag eine
Grundversorgung für die palästiner
Flüchtlinge in dieser Region
bereitzustellen bis es eine gerechte und
dauerhafte Lösung für den Konflikt gibt
wir betreiben Schulen bieten
gesundheitshilfs und Sozialdienste
an ist eine Folge des ersten
palästinerkrieges der Niederlage der
Araber und Israels Staatsgründung
1948 die Vereinten Nationen Gründen das
Hilfswerk ein Jahr später für die
palästinensischen Flüchtlinge im
Westjordanland im Gazastreifen in
Libanon Syrien und Jordanien damals rund
700.000 regelmäßig alle 3 Jahre wurde
das Mandat verlängert immer wieder steht
das hilfwerk in der Kritik vor allem in
Israel Markus Chef und seine
Organisation sind spezialisiert
Schulbücher in arabischen Ländern zu
untersuchen in den unwahchulen würden
Bücher verwendet die Terror
verherrlichen das Existenzrecht Israels
in Frage stellen
Entmenschlichung von Juden und Israelis
Juden in den Lehrbüchern sind Lügner sie
sind Betrüger und was ist ihr Schicksal
die Vernichtung und wir sagen ja für ja
in der EU in den USA und natürlich auch
der deutschen Regierung dass
Steuergelder nicht zur Finanzierung
dieses Hasses verwendet werden
dürfen 2022 bekam unwa 1,17 Milliarden
US-Dollar von den UN Mitgliedstaaten die
Hauptgeldgeber die USA mit 344 Millionen
US-Dollar gefolgt von Deutschland mit
202 Millionen und der EU mit 114
Millionen US-Dollar diese Zahlen werden
zunehmend kritisiert so sollen
mindestens 22 Lehrer des Hilfswerks das
hamasmassaker vom 7 oktober in
bejubelt haben so unw und
impact bei Schulbüchern sieht sich unwah
nicht zuständig sieht die Verantwortung
bei der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde bei Lehrkräften die
sich antisemitisch äußern ziehe man
arbeitsrechtliche Konsequenzen mit der
Hamas gebe es keine politische
Zusammenarbeit
aber wenn Sie den Gazastreifen betreten
ab einem gewissen Punkt treffen sie auf
einen Hamas Checkpoint das ist rein
technisch wenn sie rein wollen brauchen
sie de facto eine
Erlaubnis faktisch Stas im Gazastreifen
die Zivilverwaltung und ist damit
Ansprechpartner für das Hilfswerk UNRWA
hat sich als nicht in der Lage erwiesen
diese Radikalisierung zu verhindern sie
hat zwar die Menschen
alimentiert das ist auch richtig so
gewesen aber andererseits hat sie nicht
verhindern können dass es hier eine
sozusagen ein ein Brandbeschleuniger für
islamistischen Terrorismus geworden ist
eine Reform von unwa sei nötig sagen
viele Experten auch wenn vor allem die
humanitäre Arbeit des Hilfswerks gerade
jetzt nötiger ist denn
je die unra Verwalterin des Elends die
meisten ihrer Beschäftigten sind aktuell
selbst auf der Flucht und mehr als 100
ihrer Mitarbeiter wurden im aktuellen
Gazakrieg getötet sagt die UNO so viele
wie in keinem anderen Konflikt
zuvor und jetzt hier bei uns ein erster
Nachrichtenüberblick mit dir Heinz auch
rund eineinhalb Wochen nach dem
haushaltsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts wird weiter
intensiv über Konsequenzen diskutiert
unter anderem ob die Schuldenbremse
reformiert werden sollte der FDP
bundestagsfraktionsvorsitzende dürr
sagte in der zdfsendung Berlin direkt er
sei sich dessen bewusst dass die FDP mit
ihrer sehr klaren
die Schuldenbremse müsse festbleleiben
im Grundgesetz erer alleine
daastehe wenn jetzt cdoc ist und SPD und
Grüne beispielsweise das Grundgesetz
ändern würden dann stehen nur noch wir
dazwischen und die Schuldenbremse ist ja
beliebt bei den Deutschen weil sie sagen
der Staat muss auch Maßhalten der Staat
muss auch sparen deswegen wundere ich
mich schon über manche Äußerung bei SPD
und grün wussten wir das war manche
Äußerung aus der unionsfamilie auch von
Ministerpräsidenten jetzt sagen die
Schuldenbremse muss man eigentlich
schleifen und weich machen ich halte das
für falsch
nach vier Tagen ist der Bundesparteitag
der Grünen zu Ende gegangen zum
Abschluss wurden leitblanken für die
Europawahl 2024 gesetzt auf Platz 1 der
Kandidatenliste steht die europäische
grünen Fraktionschefin Terry reintke
inhaltlich soll der Fokus auf
Klimaschutz und der Transformation der
Wirtschaft liegen in der Asylpolitik
bekannten sich die Delegierten trotz
Streits zum Grundsatz Humanität und
Ordnung dies schließt auch
grundsätzliche Zustimmung zu den sich
auf europäischer Ebene abzeichnenden
asylrechtsverschärfungen nicht
aus arbeitgeberverbandspräsident Dulger
geht davon aus dass Deutschland wegen
des Fachkräftemangels an Wohlstand
einbüßen wird der Bild am Sonntag sagte
er deutschland müsse wieder attraktiv
werden für Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland
man brauche eine Willkommenskultur wie
in anderen großen
Einwanderungsländern außerdem
kritisierte Dulger die Klimapolitik als
schädlich für den
Wirtschaftsstandort der Fotograf Konrad
R Müller ist im Alter von 83 Jahren
gestorben er sei am Samstagabend einer
langen schweren Krankheit erlegen
erklärte seine Ehefrau bekannt wurde
Müller durch seine eindringlichen
schwarz-weiß Portraits aller
Bundeskanzler von Adenauer bis Scholz
Müller von vielen kanzlerfotograf
genannt nutzte nach eigener Aussage
stehs nur zwei Kameras und verzichtete
auf Scheinwerfer Stative und anderes
Zubehör neben den kanzlerbildern
verwirklichte er als freier Fotograf
zahlreiche
Fotoprojekte ab der kommenden Woche muss
sich die Welt mit sich selbst
beschäftigen mit dem Kampf gegen die
Klimakatastrophe dann ist
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai wie dringend
Ergebnisse wären zeigen die neuesten
unozahlen vom 1,5° Ziel sind wir weit
entfernt die Erde steuert auf eine
Erwärmung um 2,5° eher 3° in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten zu und das selbst
dann wenn alle klimaschutzzusagen
eingehalten werden viel zu tun auch in
einem Gebiet das niemand wirklich auf
der Rechnung hat der Gesundheitssektor
hat ein noch größeres Klimaproblem als
selbst die
Flugbranche und das gerade weil bei
Narkosen ein Stoff verwendet wird der
tausende mal klimaschädlicher ist als
CO2 Laura BIK und Josefine
Mosch sie in den Patienten schlafen
lassen Narkosegase wie Desfluran oder
Sevofluran bei Operationen in Kliniken
täglich eingesetzt aber extrem schädlich
fürs Klima gasnarkotika können bis zu
35% der Emissionen in einem Krankenhaus
verursachen viel zu viel wie Professor
Scheller vom ST Josefs Hospital in
Wiesbaden findet sie müssen sich
vorstellen wenn wir mit einem
frischgasfluss von 2 l Narkose machen
mit einem bestimmten Narkosegas dann
entsprechend a stündig Narkosen einer
Fahrt vom Kapstadt bis ans Nordkap das
sind also 15 000 km Fahrt mit einem PKW
die sie pro Tag an Klimaschädlichkeit
produzieren können Narkosegase werden
oft von Anästhesisten benutzt weil sie
gut steuerbar sind der Haken der Patient
atmet die Gase zum Teil wieder aus durch
Abluftrohre werden sie nach draußen
geleitet und belasten die
Umwelt lautbnd für Umwelt und
Naturschutz sind volatile Narkosen also
Narkosegase wie desluran
2540 mal Lachgas 300 Mal
klimaschädlicher als CO2 isofloran um
das 510fache und sevofloran 130 Mal so
schädlich Grund für die schlechte
Umweltbilanz von narkosegasen ist der
enthaltene Kohlenwasserstoff die
Moleküle würden nur langsam abgebaut
auch deshalb seien sie extrem schädlich
sagt anäesistin Sneider Ramos das ist ja
sehr es Gas das heißt es ist nicht nur
für die Dauer der Narkose
klimaschädigend sondern eben noch viele
Jahre des floran verbleibt 14 Jahre in
der Umwelt Lachgas 200 und sebbofloran
über ein Jahr ein erster Schritt für
Kliniken könnte sein auf die
umweltschädlichen Gase zu verzichten
viele Ärzte verwenden Sie dennoch
bevorzugt die Verwendung inhalativer
Narkosen ist auch historisch
gewachsen das kommt von Chloroform und
ethernarkosen die wurden bis in die 60er
Jahre durchgeführt heute haben wir die
Möglichkeit anäthesien auch über die
Vene durchzuführen und da genauso
sichere und gute Narkosen zu machen doch
machen Narkosen die beispielsweise
überwene oder durch örtliche Betäubung
verabreicht werden medizinisch einen
Unterschied das sind genauso sichere
Narkosen sie sind genauso bekömmlich und
sind im Preis keinen Unterschied zu den
volatilen Anästhetika also den narko
osegasen die wir sonst bisher verwendet
haben die Abkehr von narkosegasen
beginnt erst allmählich solange Kliniken
weiterhin gasnarkosen einsetzen könnten
Filter mit Aktivkohle den Schaden für
die Umwelt minimieren die salemklinik in
Heidelberg gehört zu den rund 30
Kliniken in Deutschland die ihre
operationszelle bereits nachgerüstet
haben Filter nimmt die Narkosegase
komplett auf und die vollen
narkosegasfilter werden dann der Firma
zugeschickt und die kann daraus über ein
aufbereitungs und
Destillationsverfahren das Narkosegas
wieder heraus lösen und das steht dann
erneut zur Verfügung also kann wieder
verwendet werden die Dringlichkeit für
Klimaschutz müsse endlich auch im
Gesundheitssektor ankommen fordert
Sneider Ramos ein erster Schritt dafür
könnte sein den Einsatz der
klimaschädlichsten Gase ohne
Filteranlagen in op-seelen bundesweit zu
verbieten zum Sport an diesem Sonntag
zuerst zur Fußball buundesliga und den
beiden Sonntagsspielen die Partie
Heidenheim gegen Bochum blieb ohne Tore
0:0 mit Toren aber ebenfalls
unentschieden das Spiel Hoffenheim gegen
Mainz Endstand
1:1 Union Berlin hat einen neuen
Cheftrainer verpflichtet nenard bjelizza
der 52-Jährige stand zuletzt beim
türkischen Erstligisten trabson Spor
untervertrag und ist in Berlin
Nachfolger von Urs Fischer
die Formel 1 Saison ist heute in Abu
Dhabi mit einem weiteren Sieg von
Weltmeister Max Verstappen zu Ende
gegangen es war sein 19 Sieg im 22
Rennen auf Platz 2 fuhr heute Charles
Leclaire dritter wurde George
Russell die deutschen Biathletinnen und
Biathleten hatten heute beim Weltcup in
Östersund einen sehr erfolgreichen Tag
erst wurde im einzelüber 15 km Franziska
Pru mit nur 0,1 Sekunden Rückstand
zweite hinter der Italienerin Lisa vzi
und Vanessa Vogt kam auf Platz 3 und
dann feierte auch noch Roman re seinen
ersten Weltcup
Sieg damit hat keiner gerechnet den
deutschen Biathleten gelingt ein
sensationeller Doppelerfolg Roman Rees
gewinnt das Einzelrennen vor seinem
Teamkollegen Justus strelo Topfavorit
Johannes tingesbö kämpft wird nach zwei
schießfehlerern aber nur Dritter die
zwei deutschen Athleten leisten sich in
dem Rennen auf der schweren Strecke in
östersind nur eine Strafminute der
30-Jährige re feiert den ersten
Weltcupsieg seiner Karriere für strelo
ist es der erste Podestplatz in einem
Einzelrennen und dann gucken wir jetzt
traditionell auf das was kommt in der
Woche vor uns hier ist der heute journal
Ausblick von Dara Hassan
[Musik]
sad am Dienstag werden sich die NATO
Außenminister in Brüssel einfinden und
sich zu Beginn der Konferenz einer Frage
widmen kommt Schweden in die NATO bevor
es zur feierlichen Aufnahme Schwedens in
das Verteidigungsbündnis kommen kann
müssen noch das ungarische und das
türkische Parlament zustimmen Diplomaten
in Brüssel halten dies trotz des
inzwischen erheblichen Zeitdrucks für
möglich eine weitere Verzögerung der
Ratifizierungen allerdings
auch mit oder ohne Schweden als
Neumitglied am Mittwoch wird das Treffen
der NATO auenminister ganz im Zeichen
der Ukraine stehen der ukrainische
Außenminister Kleber wird zu einem
offiziellen Treffen des NATO ukrainerats
erwartet die Fragen liegen auf der Hand
was braucht die Ukraine was macht die
Gegenoffensive und wo steht die Ukraine
auf ihrem Weg in die NATO am Donnerstag
werden viele Außenminister weiterreisen
ins nordmazedonische scopier dort wird
es zum schicksalsgipfel der OSZE kommen
und seit langem wieder zu einem Treffen
mit dem russischen Außenminister
lavrowov Russland und belaruss
blockieren die OSZE mit ihren Vetos bis
hin zur
Handlungsunfähigkeit sperren sich gegen
Estland als neuen Vorsitz und gegen den
Haushalt kommt es zu keiner Einigung
dann wird die usosze Deo am Ende sein 48
Jahre nach Unterzeichnung der KSZE
Schlussakte von
Helsinki und noch die Wetteraussichten
zum Start in die neueewoche morgen fällt
viel Regen oder Schnee auf bis in tiefe
Lagen dabei kann es glatt werden etwas
Sonne gibt es nur an der Ostsee und am
Alpenrand die Temperatur erreicht 0 bis
6° die nächsten Tage werden mit -3 bis +
5° noch etwas kälter und es bleibt nass
mit Regen und Schnee oft bis in die
Niederungen im Bergland wird es
hochwinterlich ja das Kühler Aussichten
das war unsere heute journal
Sonntagsausgabe und um 0:30 uhrb dann
die nächste heute Express bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen aber erst von uns allen
hier Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
wiedersehen